bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur
tvfils 78 pour une nouvelle édition du 7
8 il est 18h si vous nous rejoignez en
direct comme chaque soir du lundi au
jeudi 1er invité déjà présent sur ce
plateau en ce mercredi 20 mars le
président de la Croix-Rouge Croix-Rouge
pardon sur Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
Jean-Luc Ghislain bonsoir à vous bonsoir
et merci d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation on va parler avec vous de vos
différentes activités elles sont
nombreuses à aide alimentaire
vestimentaires secourisme également
beaucoup de champs d'intervention et
puis ce rapport que vous avez publié
rapport de vos activités en 2012 et qui
a été remis d'ailleurs en début de
semaine au Ministre Benoît Hamon lors de
sa visite sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines on va parler
de tout ça dans quelques minutes
auparavant voici les titres qui les
sujets qui seront développés au cours de
la prochaine heure en images la Zoé le
nouveau modèle de voiture électrique
développé par Renault est un produit
yvelinois conçu au Technocentre de
Guyancourt assemblée à l'usine de Flins
une citadine verte qui présente de
nouvelles avancées technologiques
pour que les enfants n'aient pas peur de
côtoyer l'hôpital des étudiants de
médecine de la Faculté des sciences de
50 ans en Yvelines proposent pendant une
semaine l'Hôpital des Nounours rencontre
avec de nounours d'ailleurs Léa et Oscar
tout à l'heure et puis les étudiants qui
s'occupent de cet hôpital seront aussi
avec nous une compétition
d'aéromodélisme
48 concurrents internationaux ils ont dû
réaliser des figures avec leurs avions
en modèle réduit un Guyancourtois se
place deuxième de cette compétition
internationale donc et puis Oscar Abbey
à La Verrière un cours de danse
irlandaise un atelier qui se déroule
avant le bal de la Saint-Patrick prévu
ce vendredi soir
à la culture ce sera aussi avec Aurélia
Debussy bonsoir Aurélia on vous retrouve
au début de la seconde partie de cette
édition dans à peu près une demi-heure
exactement alors nous recevrons deux
personnes la première monsieur lune donc
qui est un artiste de la scène française
et qui mène en parallèle des ateliers
d'écriture avec les enfants des écoles
de Magny-les-Hameaux qui viendra nous
parler de ses ateliers également Michel
bocage qui est le président le directeur
du festival Jazz à toute heure et qui
viendra nous raconter sa sélection son
choix de programmation cette année et
nous ferons un détour également par le
festival de Rocquencourt qui démarre ce
soir pour trois dates nous verrons
qu'elles sont peut-être les futurs
talents du rire de demain musique et
humour à tout à l'heure Aurélia pour
cette chronique et puis cette
information aussi à vous donner pour
débuter cette édition du 7-8 Alain
Schmitz le président du Conseil général
des Yvelines qui s'est rendu aujourd'hui
mercredi 20 mars à l'Assemblée nationale
dans le cadre d'une audition sur le
Grand Paris vous le savez le dossier a
avancé avec les annonces faites il y a
quelques semaines par le premier
ministre c'était l'occasion pour le
président du conseil général de rappeler
la position des Yvelines de regretter
également que la ligne verte entre
Saclay et Versailles et dorénavant
baptisé ligne 18 soit repoussée à 2030
tout de même un point de satisfaction
pour lui cette ligne Éole actée jusqu'à
Mantes-la-Jolie elle le président du
Conseil général des Yvelines qui
souhaitent aussi insister sur le
développement territorial de l'oïen
l'opération d'intérêt national de Saclay
dont les contrats ne sont pas encore
réalisés voilà pour ce point pour cette
actualité on passe à présent donc à la
Zoé c'est le nouveau véhicule tout
électrique de Renault qui arrive sur le
marché nous l'avons testé pour vous les
premières impressions de Claire Cambier
la Zoé fait ses premiers tours de roue
sur le bitume la nouvelle voiture
électrique de Renault et yvelinoise
conçue au Technocentre de Guyancourt et
produite à Flins elle vient d'être
lancée sur le marché premier atout son
prix 13700 euros grâce au bonus
écologique de 7000 euros l'équivalent de
la Clio diesel autre nouveauté une
autonomie plus importante de 110 km
homologués soit 150 km d'autonomie
réelle et pour cela Renault a intégré
des innovations technologiques une pompe
à chaleur pour faire la climatisation ou
le chauffage ce qui va permettre de
consommer trois fois moins qu'un système
conventionnel des pneus Michelin énergie
vit à faible frottement dans Zoé à
l'exclusivité et enfin un système de
récupération d'énergie au freinage de
toute nouvelle génération autre point
noir souvent évoqué la recharge la Zoé a
intégré un chargeur embarqué caméléon
qui s'adapte automatiquement à la
puissance de la borne de recharge
de 30 minutes à 9 heures pour une charge
complète un câble est fourni pour se
brancher sur les bornes publiques ou sur
la wall box à installer chez soi pas de
problème de vol pour le retirer il faut
avoir la clé malgré ses efforts cette 5
places avec boîte automatique à ces
réactives avec ses 88 chevaux n'en reste
pas moins une citadine c'est une voiture
qui sera vraiment agréable à conduire
tout au long de la semaine et qui vous
permettra également de faire des
économies puisque passer dix mille
kilomètres par an ça va revenir beaucoup
moins cher de rouler un électrique 10000
km pour rentabiliser le coût de la
location de la batterie 79 euros par
mois un seuil qui pourrait se réduire si
le prix à la pompe augmente au delà de
l'aspect technique la Zoé plaît aussi
pour son design à l'intérieur un tableau
de bord qui évoque une palle d'éolienne
un volant modulable et surtout un
tableau tactile qui propose navigation
par GPS disponibilité des bornes de
recharge et une multitude d'applications
comme Coyote des flux d'information ou
l'accès aux réseaux sociaux et pour le
modèle zen diffuseur de senteurs peut
être l'astuce pour respecter la semaine
de la courtoisie au volant
le fait du jour de ce 20 mars c'est la
Croix-Rouge de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
qui fait le point sur son action à
travers et son bilan son rapport annuel
Jean-Luc Ghislain son président va
commenter avec nous ce bilan à commencer
par ce chiffre le chiffre de cette
édition 20 000 c'est le nombre d'heures
de bénévolat qui vous ont permis de
réaliser vos différentes missions une
centaine de bénévoles qui a œuvré
pendant 20 000 heures quels commentaires
on peut apporter sur ce chiffre est-ce
que c'est suffisant satisfaisant est-ce
que c'est un chiffre aussi en hausse ce
qui voudrait dire que les besoins de la
population aussi ont augmenté quelle
analyse vous en faites
ça alors c'est un chiffre en haut ce oui
parce que les besoins ont augmenté oui
parce que nous essayons d'être beaucoup
plus de plus en plus professionnel dans
notre approche de manière à être plus
près de de toutes les demandes de
statistiques qui peuvent nous être
faites par les différentes
administrations aussi parce que nous
essayons d'être plus disponible pour
donc bénéficiaires je dirais que c'est
même la première raison pour laquelle
nous avons besoin de plus de bénévoles
de manière à les accompagner le plus
possible
dans toutes les tous les besoins qu'ils
peuvent avoir que ce soit de relation
avec l'administration
ou les différentes administrations
d'ailleurs quelle qu'elle soit les
caisses allocations familiales ou les
caisses de retraite que ce soit même à
l'interne pour nous pour être sûr que
les accueils que nous faisons nous
réalisons soit aussi en rapport avec les
attentes des bénéficiaires tous les
besoins je veux dire le nombre d'heures
de bénévolat ce nombre d'heures est
suffisant
il faudrait plus de bénévoles plus de
temps passé oui si on avait plus de
bénévoles on pourrait augmenter je veux
dire que si je prends un fait récent
nous avons ouvert notre halte répit pour
les malades d'elzheimer à Maurepas elle
est pratiquement pleine maintenant le
samedi après-midi donc on commence à
avoir des demandes de lire faudrait
ouvrir une autre demi-journée dans la
semaine donc on va probablement lancer
une recherche de bénévoles pour
spécifique pour cette action là mais
c'est vrai aussi dans l'action
alimentaire bien que bon on puisse pas
mettre beaucoup plus de bénévoles parce
que il y aura pas de place pour les
bénéficiaires si on met trop de
bénévoles les structures sont trop
petits mais
on essaie autant que faire ce peu de de
répondre à tous les besoins alors
nos bénévoles sont aussi un peu comme
dans toutes les actions de bénévolat
certains vieillissent donc il faut les
remplacer il faut il se fatiguent un peu
plus vite vous avez une mentionnés tout
à l'heure le travail que vous menez sur
la halte répit détente qui est sur la
ville de Maurepas on voit des images de
l'épicerie sociale donc est situé sur
sur trappes je reviens juste sur cette
alter epidante c'est un projet que vous
aviez lancé en 2012 qui a vu le jour
véritablement cette année 2013 on en
avait
parlées fin 2012 on rappelle le
fonctionnement après-midi le samedi
après-midi
donc vous recevez que vous accueillez ça
permet aux proches aux familles qui
s'occupent des malades au quotidien de
souffler un petit peu ça fait partie de
vos activités on va parler de l'ensemble
de des activités justement que vous
menez faire un petit peu le bilan sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines de l'action de
la Croix-Rouge juste auparavant je le
disais tout à l'heure au début de cette
émission vous avez remis votre rapport
votre bilan annuel à Benoît Hamon le
ministre par ailleurs élu député de la
circonscription celle qui couvre 50 ans
en Yvelines en grande partie vous en
attendez quoi de cette remise de rapport
et de bilans c'est pour alerter aussi le
gouvernement à travers
vous savez tout le monde a entendu
parler de la diminution des des
subventions européennes donc ça
représente le fameux plan d'aide
européen qui représente pour nos 20% de
nos ressources
alimentaires bon c'est important que ce
que tout le monde au niveau du
gouvernement se rendent bien compte de
l'importance bon Benoît Hamon était déjà
venu nous voir auparavant il a fait
remarquer d'ailleurs parce que il paraît
qu'on lui remet un rapport à chaque fois
on rate pas les occasions
et donc on a profité de de du fait qu'il
était intéressé à visiter l'épicerie
sociale de Trappes puisqu'il connaissait
celle d'énancourt pour
remettre en avant toutes nos besoins
tous nos problèmes et toutes nos
problématiques
nous pouvons rencontrer tous les jours
du fait justement de la réduction du
PEAD se plantait d'Européen alors c'est
au niveau européen justement que toutes
les associations qui touchent des sous
qui permettent d'alimenter un petit peu
les caisses et vous permettre de venir
en aide à ces différents besoins
quotidiens de la population le fait que
cette aide soient réduit vous disiez
c'est 20 %, ça veut dire que votre
action va se réduire également dans les
prochaines années non ça veut dire qu'on
va travailler plus pour trouver un moyen
de compenser alors pour l'instant l'État
a promis de compenser donc on va voir
parce que cette année c'est 200 tonnes
de marchandises que vous avez distribué
donc
une quarantaine de tonnes sont venus de
la Banque Alimentaire oui donc au
travers au travers de la Banque
Alimentaire une grande partie c'est du
PED et quelquefois ces besoins en plus
sont en hausse ponctuelle puisqu'on
parle de ce bilan annuel sur l'année
2012 cette année vous avez fait face
également il a fallu absorber de
nouvelles populations l'arrivée de
réfugiés venue de Tchétchénie de Géorgie
et qui ont été placés par le Samu social
dans les différents hôtels de la région
sur trappes sur Coignières aussi il y a
eu les ROM aussi sur la base de loisirs
de 50 ans en Yvelines ce sont des
populations qui sont venues frapper à
votre porte et il a fallu répondre à
leurs besoins tout à fait on peut pas
les laisser ce sont parmi les gens les
plus démunis que nous puissions en
rencontrer parce que cela non dans la
majorité ils n'ont pas de logement nous
n'ont pas de le même pas le droit de
travailler dans beaucoup de cas donc les
ressources sont très limitées donc on
peut pas les laisser complètement
démunis et on a choisi plutôt que de
leur distribuer des colis de leur donner
un accès à nos épiceries en leur on leur
a louant un budget d'achat en fonction
de la taille de la famille bon c'est
vrai que l'inconvénient pour nous c'est
que financièrement ce sont des aides que
nous donnons pour lesquelles nous
n'avons aucune aide nous de notre part
qui vous sont allés par l'État par
exemple nous avons aucun niveau non le
le 115 de Paris qui a placé ses familles
paix les chambres d'hôtel et le reste
bah il faut qu'elle se débrouille donc
donc nous on doit se débrouiller
également et ces populations sont encore
là aujourd'hui on parlait de l'année
2012 même oui je crois qu'il y en a de
plus en plus parce qu'on découvre de
nouveaux arrivants maintenant dans nos
nouveaux hôtels qui n'étaient pas connus
auparavant on a maintenant des gens sur
maurent pas qu'on avait pas auparavant
on a d'autres hôtels qui sont ouverts
sur Coignières donc euh
je crois que là où les hôtels ont trouvé
une mine d'ouverture de revenus
supplémentaires en acceptant quelques
familles comme ça supplémentaires ce qui
leur permet d'avoir un taux de
remplissage plus important pour les
familles c'est mieux que d'être c'est
l'État qui paye les chambres d'hôtel
voilà voilà d'un autre côté pour les
familles c'est mieux que d'être à la rue
donc c'est c'est une ce je refuse je ne
critique surtout pas le fait que les
hôtels s'ouvrent bon par contre la
manière dont on gère ces familles c'est
un peu inhumain bon c'est vrai qu'on
peut pas supporter tous les malheurs du
monde comme a dit à nos anciens premiers
ministres mais
de l'autre côté de la manière dont on
les gère
pour moi complètement inhumaine c'est à
dire quand on voit que ces gens arrivent
bon on leur trouve un logement c'est
bien mais leur dossier de de demande
d'accès ou de demande de documents on ne
sera traité que dans 6 mois dans la
majorité des cas donc
et ils sont ils sont placés là avec une
garantie de rester dans cet endroit là
pendant un mois de voir deux mois et
puis il faut attendre la fin des deux
mois pour savoir s'ils vont rester là si
on va les déplacer ailleurs c'est c'est
une situation qui est pour moi une
admissible mais bon
justement frapper à vos portes dans les
différentes épiceries sociales pour
avoir des aides alimentaires elles sont
pas forcément très encadrées et il faut
ensuite nouer le contact et à la
barrière de la langue qui se pose et ça
reste un petit peu difficile est-ce que
vous alerter aussi les pouvoirs publics
sur ces questions là est-ce que vous
avez rencontré les élus est-ce que vous
avez rencontré j'ai rencontré les
députés j'ai rencontré les les
conseillers généraux j'ai rencontré les
mers je dois de nouveau rencontrer
certains maires parce que je je trouve
normal que les mères disent ce ne sont
pas des habitants de notre commune d'un
autre côté ce sont quand même des
habitants puisqu'ils ont tout à fait une
résidence qui leur a été allouée bon on
n'a pas choisi non plus non pas choisi
donc je suis en train de me battre pour
que les commun les reconnaissent comme
des habitants normaux et les prennent en
charge dans les CCAS dans les écoles
c'est fait c'est la loi ils sont obligés
de les prendre mais encore que bon dans
les collèges et les lycées c'est un peu
plus difficile et il faut vraiment se
battre pour que ça arrive à passer mais
les écoles primaires toutes les communes
ont accepté les enfants dans les écoles
primaires dans les écoles maternelles et
plus de réticence mais enfin ça arrive à
passer maintenant aussi
c'est bon c'est un travail de tous les
jours il faut on les voit toutes les
semaines on parle avec eux on voit
comment la situation évoluer
heureusement qu'il y a des associations
comme les médecins bannir bénévoles par
exemple qu'ils ont aidé en faisant
toutes les vaccinations nécessaires pour
être scolarisés
c'est enfin bref je suis outré de la
manière dont on est on les accepte c'est
où on en veut pas et on les renvoie où
on les accepte et on les traite
correctement mais la situation actuelle
pour moi est inadmissible voilà le
message est passé en tout cas et il
était très clair sur ces populations
supplémentaires en tout cas qui que vous
avez accueilli notamment au cours de
cette année 2012
au-delà de ça au delà de cette aide
alimentaire que vous apportez pour tout
le monde parce que c'est pour les
réfugiés il y a d'autres activités que
vous menez on peut aussi les évoquer ce
soir il y a la vestiboutique par exemple
aussi voilà quel bilan vous en faites
sur cette année 2012 ben nous avons plus
de 2000 familles qui sont passées au
total entre les les
d'une barre tous les réfugiés parce que
ils arrivent avec une valise ou de
valises donc il faut les aussi les
habiller mais nous avons des étudiants
nous avons la vestiboutique est ouverte
à tout le monde et nous sommes
distribuons des bons d'achat pour que
les gens n'aient pas à payer les
quelques centimes que nous demandons
pour chaque vêtement
ce qui nous permet les centimes que nous
demandons pour chaque vêtement nous
permettre d'acheter ce que nous n'avons
pas par ailleurs comme les
sous-vêtements par exemple que nous
récupérons avec plus de difficultés ou
des chaussures par exemple également le
besoin les demandes en tout cas sont en
hausse sur les vêtements par exemple
aussi parce qu'on parle souvent des
animaux
est difficile pour tout le monde donc
comme quand on parle d'aide alimentaire
pour nous il y a ça veut dire aussi
l'hygiène les produits d'entretien et
tout ça parce que ces gens doivent se
laver les dents dans se raser de se
laver les cheveux donc ils ont besoin de
shampoing ils ont besoin de lessive ils
ont besoin de de papier hygiénique enfin
des trucs idiots mais bon il faut quand
même les acheter donc on a ça dans nos
épiceries à la vestibouti qu'on a les
vêtements les sous-vêtements les
chaussures
éventuellement des draps et autres donc
tout ce qu'on peut récupérer tout ce qui
est vraiment en bon état et
systématiquement recyclé
et puis nous nous sommes organisés pour
recycler ce qui n'est pas recyclable au
sein de l'investiboutique parce que
c'est pendant ces bon état parce qu'il
manque des boutons parce que parce que
ceci parce que cela et nous
les revendons à une entreprise de
recyclage disons qui ont ensuite les
transforme en chiffon ou éventuellement
en bourre pour fabriquer des voitures ou
autres il vous ne manquez pas d'activité
avec vos nombreux bénévoles qui
interviennent tout au long de l'année
sur Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines leur
tourne nous restait peu de temps mais
j'aimerais tout de même qu'on aborde de
dossiers de questions très rapidement
sur les activités que vous menez tout
d'abord sur le secourisme ça aussi on en
parle moins mais ça fait partie des
activités qui se développent vous aider
aussi les formations de premiers secours
de plus en plus de personnes souhaitent
être formées et vous intervenez aussi la
Croix-Rouge de Saint-Quentin même ses
actions oui oui puisque chaque fois
qu'il y a une grosse manifestation sur
sur Saint-Quentin bon nous sommes
souvent appelés pour tenir un poste de
secours pour nous occuper des
éventuelles blessés malades ou autres
qui pourraient subvenir donc de ce fait
nous faisons de la formation parce que
nous la formation de nos propres
bénévoles représente déjà des centaines
d'heures de formation que nous devons
mettre en place donc ça nous a amené à
avoir des formateurs et nous utilisons
ces formateurs pour les mettre à
disposition du grand public
donc ça nous fait deux activités
supplémentaires qui se complémentent le
nom
et puis si on reste dans les actions
nous sommes en train de mettre en place
une équipe jeunesse aussi pour les
jeunes de de 12 à 20 ans à peu près pour
les former un peu à l'action du
bénévolat leur montrer tout ce qu'ils
peuvent apporter aux gens en difficulté
ils ont leur propre action ils vont dans
des maisons de retraite pour faire des
lotos et autres et bon alors c'est un
embryon d'équipe pour l'instant ça
démarre c'est les jeunes c'est plus
difficile à fidéliser c'est plus
difficile à intéresser sur le long terme
est passé si vous êtes jeune si vous
souhaitez rejoindre les équipes de la
Croix-Rouge on arrive à la fin de cet
entretien on arrive aussi à la comme
l'hiver on le dirait pas mais pourtant
c'est bientôt la fin de l'hiver on va
plutôt sur le printemps et là où je vais
en venir c'est que vos actions vont se
poursuivre avec ces maraude que vous
menez l'action que vous menez auprès des
SDF ce n'est pas uniquement l'hiver que
vous allez à la rencontre de ces
populations sans domicile fixe non tout
à fait de toute façon nous avons des
équipes qui tournent toutes l'année
systématiquement dans tout le
département et nous de Saint-Quentin
nous intervenants une fois toutes les
toutes les semaines à peu près
en renfort ou de ces équipes
départementales ou éventuellement un
maraude local pour aider les les SDF que
nous pouvons connaître sur le secteur
alors souvent ceux qui sont établis je
veux dire à demeure parce qu'il y en a
qui sont établis à demeure bon on leur
donne des bons d'achats pour venir dans
nos épiceries sociales au moins on est
sûr qu'ils ont peuvent avoir à manger
pour pas très cher ou pas pour rien
majorité des cas et puis les les autres
ben on va les on va à la pêche à la
maraude le soir pourraient voir comment
on peut les aider on leur emmenant des
couvertures on leur amenant
de la chaleur humaine parce que si je
pense que c'est ça qui leur manque le
plus souvent et vous allez continuer
tout au long de l'année c'est tout au
long de l'année que les équipes de la
Croix-Rouge interviennent merci Jean-Luc
Ghislain d'être venu faire ce petit
bilan de ses activités en 2012 on
retiendra notamment un c'est quelques 20
millers de bénévolat distribués grâce
aux différentes actions que vous avez pu
faire et puis ce coup de gueule aussi
vous avez passé tout à l'heure sur
l'accueil des réfugiés et des
populations qui viennent sur le
territoire et qui sont pas forcément
accueillies dans de très très bonnes
conditions et que vous recevez notamment
dans vos épiceries sociales reportage à
présent avant de d'accueillir dans un
instant des étudiants en médecine qui
accueillent de drôles de passion avec
l'Hôpital des Nounours un reportage sur
l'aéro modélisme avec un tournoi
international qui vient de se tenir aux
Clayes-sous-Bois des amateurs de modèles
réduits de toute l'Europe et même un peu
au-delà qui se sont réunis pendant
plusieurs jours les images
parmi les 48 pilotes internationaux
présents à ce concours ce week-end aux
Clayes-sous-Bois beaucoup ont sûrement
un jour rêvé d'être aux commandes d'un
avion de ligne mais leurs appareils à
eux ne mesurent pas plus d'un mètre et
pèse entre 50 et 100 g lors d'un
concours des héros modélisme chaque
pilote effectue un balai plein
d'émotions pendant 3 minutes l'avion
épouse les notes de musique une
chorégraphie imposée ponctuée de
renversement et de cercles en tonneaux
de toute beauté
chaque pilote doit dans le temps en
partie réaliser sa propre chorégraphie
avec la musique de son choix on peut
inventer des figures pour impressionner
le public en espérant qu'il apprécie
à côté des Français champion du monde
par équipe j'ai frais concours dans la
catégorie promotion il vole depuis 5 ans
et rencontre pour la première fois ces
rois des airs c'est un rêve parce que
on les voit sur les magazines etc et là
le fait de le croiser et de discuter
avec lui ma difficulté ça c'est
incroyable
sans surprise le champion du monde
autrichien garde notre brokeman c'est
imposé dans les airs devant le
Guyancourtois Nicolas pietu licencié au
club des clés du ciel